ça fait deux ans mais sa femme est à une
éternité sénat dim 10h quand ça va pas
je regarde la vidéo et ça
malheureusement ce genre de message tu
t'attends pas à quoi c'est ça qui me
touche c'est des gens qui te dit que tu
es en question n'est pas un étudiant ça
que je vais être qu'enfin plat comme 10
avril
fillon et fait sens
c'est comme ça
c'est ça
on se retrouve ici chez toi en corse
deux ans après est quelque chose qui a
changé maintenant j'assume en laissant
de marbre et mon élection quoi ce
n'était pas le cas il ya deux ans et
savoir que c'est un sétois contexte l
ontt idiot takara bien tout le monde de
s'assumer comme comme ça à ton tour
maintenant j'ai toujours parlé j'étais
un peu discret ces libérations tu veux
je m'assure avec mes défauts que j'aime
pas trois ans accepte pas que ça qui a
changé ton environnement aussi changé je
vous présente mon organisation
organisation peu plus d'appui à moi
bonsoir à tous alors ouais
[Musique]
c'est l'acceptation de t'avoir qui
doivent pousser à te lancer sur pitch
c'est dans un coin de ma tête car car
plus dur c'est sympa futur mais je
disais faire un coup ce qu'à l'écrire ça
va être long le but c'est arrivé je suis
belle occasion fait mon but c'est
vraiment grâce à ma petite notoriété de
montrer à tout le monde c'est possible
ça marche on est de retour avec mon pote
moi mes doigts si tmc
elle était partie pilou c'est quelqu'un
qui s'est construit tout seul il y a
montré que les handicaps qui a montré
des difficultés n'étaient pas à même ce
tacle filou c'est une force de
conviction chez nous c'est une force de
2 de persuasion et c'est aussi un roc
en fait fidel où ils le montrent que les
difficultés il en a transformé une vague
d'amour et que l'amour qu'il a en lui
ce coeur qu'il a pour les gens cette
bienveillance là il en a construit une
force qui est magnifique et aujourd'hui
tu es devenu pour plus de 250000
personnes accompagnant en fait ça te
fait quoi toi fils ou d'entendre ce que
je ne te dire ça me vient comme en
commun mohamed
j'ai eu une enfance très compliqué et
que pas habitués mais parce que je ne
suis pas habitué à ce qu'on fasse autant
de concurrents quelque chose qui
imposait sa démarche année tu veux
ajouter quelque chose
merci cinq lettres
kiki qui s'opèrent défaut merci